you look stunning thank you very much we
gotta ask love that you're here how is
Liam doing Liam's feeling good he has to
you know rest up but he loves this film
he's so proud of it and I really wanted
to be able to represent it Fran
we heard hospitalized what's wrong is he
okay yeah he'll be okay you know just
you need to take care of himself and
getting healthy is more important than
anything else so I'm here to represent I
had my dress already and I couldn't let
it go to waste
look amazing and you're we do
Valentine's Day coming up who's more
romantic you early amande what are the
plan neither of us will end up probably
eating something like disgusting like
Chinese food in bed all day are you
feeling what I'm feeling how is your
life like a rom-com um that maybe it
never goes exactly how I think it's
going to but somehow it always ends up
being better is it amazing like you and
Liam newlyweds and you're here on the
premiere of is carpet how crazy is I
know so low but not exactly how I
expected it but I'm happy to be here and
represented like I said way Congrats on
the Grammys how awesome was performing
with Dolly 40 it was so awesome and I'm
happy to be here and that was just an
awesome experience music between you and
Shawn please thank you so much thank you
[Music]
[Applause]